okay so we're continuing our coverage
and getting caught up on uh the various
x-men related stories right because
we've just we've been slacking in recent
months and so what we're doing here is
we're picking up with marauders with the
wrath of iceman and here's the thing you
don't normally see bobby drake just lose
it right and there's a couple reasons
for that one because of the fact that
bobby drake is an omega level mutant
even he doesn't fully understand the
totality of his powers in comparison to
when emma frost took over his body and
pushed them to the limit right so in a
lot of ways he's still learning what
he's capable of but two because of the
nature of his powers if he lost control
in the extreme this guy is powerful
enough to just eliminate all life on
earth right just wipe out everything on
the face of the planet even kill the
earth itself what this does here is this
initially picks up with callisto and i
love callisto callisto's old school
right those guys who are are new to
marvel comics callisto's been around for
a long long time and she led or really
rose to prominence under claremont's run
in leading a group called the morlocks
now the idea behind this is that at one
point in time calista was actually a
model and she was gorgeous and she still
is to a degree the big issue here is
that once her mutant powers emerged she
was actually stabbed and ended up
scarred hence the reason why she wears
the eye patch but because she had
basically lost her modeling career and
then following that the basically being
injured as a result of being a mutant
she came to the realization that
humanity hated mutants in that way and
her modeling career was over because you
know in her mind who wanted a model that
was missing an eye and so what she did
is she went underground in an old
abandoned military silo in manhattan and
then basically started organizing and
basically bringing together the warlocks
which were in a lot of ways truth to
tell the island of misfit toys right
just mutants who couldn't quite make it
out there in the world because their
mutant powers had manifested in ways
that created physical deformities now
the really significant thing with
callisto was the battle she had with
storm back in the 80s when storm
basically ended up taking over as the
leader of the morlocks and calista was
basically just kind of like her her
steward right she's like the ceo of
youtube she just runs the place while
the advertisers are away
but no in all seriousness callisto
basically ran the warlocks while storm
was gone right and it was a way for
storm to basically assert her dominance
and to say yes i'm the leader of the
morlocks but also allow callisto to
maintain her dignity and keeping her
role as the leader of the morlocks and
so the result of this is that of course
with everything going on in krakowa the
callisto is now here on oncrocoa and
basically working alongside pretty much
all the other mutants that are you know
operating in this place and so one of
the funny things here is that she's
given an offer by emma frost which is
basically for callisto to become the
white knight of the of the marauders
right the hellfire club they kind of
give her a a rank among this particular
organization now initially callisto
seems to be hesitant against it but in
all honesty it's a pretty big promotion
when it comes to the nation of cocoa one
thing that i want to specify here when
it comes to kokoa 95
of occupants there just sort of live and
they probably end up performing what are
basically menial tasks when it comes to
society as a whole right making food or
something like that a task where they
could just be easily replaced by anybody
else and then you have individuals out
there that play more significant tasks
the marauders are exceedingly important
because they basically go out into the
world find mutants that are being held
against their will free them and then
give them the option to come to krakowa
or to strike out on their own and try to
make a life for themselves outside of
kokoa and so callisto being granted this
opportunity is due to the role she
played in being a founder of the
morlocks she's got experience with this
right and so what you end up doing is
switching over to what is basically
the entire group being observed right
callisto meaning with bishop and then
greeting storm again which initially she
kind of approaches her as an enemy and
then it's just like i haven't seen you
in forever girl hey girl you look good
girl that's basically the whole thing
that's going on between these two but
ultimately the reason why they're being
watched is because there's basically a
spy among their ranks right now they are
being watched by what's called the
virindi and we've talked about the
virundi before right cade kilgore who's
probably the most underrated villain in
the entirety of marvel comics kid has no
power whatsoever but he's got no
abilities but he killed his dad took
over his empire and basically recreated
the hellfire club the kid's awesome
right he's just he's one of those kids
that's just that smart right and so
what's been going on here is much like
the original hellfire club emma frost
sebastian shaw donald pierce and all
those guys that what you have the
virindi doing is basically working
behind the scenes consolidating power
creating networks of people whom they
can use who they can provide information
to they can provide them with things and
so what's been going on here is that
with them having a source among the
mutant population one who could
potentially travel in and out of krakowa
then what it means is that information
can be brokered and that is huge knowing
the goings-on of what's taking place in
the mutant nation of cocoa which is off
limits to anybody who is not a mutant is
astronomical information they're
brokering this with the russian
government because one it's the russian
government when are they not up to some
nefarious stuff and two because the
russian government is actually
developing technology that can be
weaponized to basically take away mutant
powers or just kill mutants entirely and
so what we end up learning is the
weapons they've kind of been working on
initially could only fit in armors and
now they've basically shrunk it down to
where they can put it in a handgun right
in a pistol that can be used to
basically kill mutants and so following
this you actually pick up with bishop
who infiltrates a location and then in
turn is actually met by the arrival of
manuel anduki i think is how you
pronounce it enduc i'm not sure how you
pronounce his name basically his family
hails from african slave traders so the
guy's pretty nefarious but nonetheless
ultimately bishop gets the upper hand on
this guy and then basically manages to
stow away aboard a ship and the idea
here is to use the information they have
to get to mag report now remember this
is the nature of magipur itself if
you're an x-man or if you're like an
avenger or an agent of shield or
something like that you don't just walk
into madrid right there aren't really
any rules there i mean there are there's
a kind of code of conduct but it's no
man's land right like walking into
madrid and saying everyone freeze i'm an
agent of shield that's not going to get
them to stop by virtue of your authority
that's going to get you killed right so
madra poor is a very very dangerous
place also one of the coolest places in
marvel comics what can i say i love
dangerous and villainous places that's
why i keep telling you guys man i'd be a
bad guy dude if i had powers
i would be a dick
i would just do terribly villainous
things i'm sorry i mean i wouldn't kill
people but i'd probably rob folks right
don't judge me you guys will do the same
thing too so once this all kind of kicks
off right once everything sort of goes
on you switch over to the the quiet
console itself this is not overly
important but one of the things to
remember in the previous story that we
covered with the marauders technically
kitty pry's the leader of the team but
sebastian shaw killed her right just
like sprayed her down threw her over the
ship and called it a day and so nobody
really knows that sebastian shaw killed
kitty pride emma frost seems to kind of
have some inclination that maybe
something's going on and she could read
the mind of sebastian shaw but one of
the things that takes place among the
quiet council is they're all equal
members and so reading the mind of
sebastian shaw would be like treating
him like a subordinate right doing it
without his permission is a violation
and so that would actually get emma
frost kicked off the quiet council and
possibly even thrown in the prison in
krakowa and so it's something that she
just doesn't do plus it's just a general
respect for the people who are equal to
you and your position and so what you
end up getting here is bishop on his way
to magiport right to basically
infiltrate or gain information they can
on who it is that's quote unquote
working against them behind the scenes
and while he's on this sub or while he's
on this boat he actually stumbles across
the body of uh of kitty pride now of
course the body's also discovered by the
crew themselves but this hits emma frost
pretty hard right because she's like
okay so we finally know what happened to
kitty pride she's basically dead when
the body's recovered by these russian
soldiers if you want to call him that
along with bishop of course who's posing
as one that basically emma frost who's
in a telepathic connection with bishop
confirms the body's dead but bishop also
takes one of the ropes that were used to
bind kitty pride's legs and then in turn
they end up discovering that bishop is
actually a mutant and ultimately because
of the fact that he'd been in contact
with emma frost and because he'd said we
found the body of kitty pride the number
one motivation of emma was get the body
of kitty pride right we're not gonna let
the body of of one of our greatest
mutants fall in the hands of humans that
would basically do terrible things to it
right that would string it up put it on
public display parade it around the
world saying we killed a mutant using it
for propaganda purposes different things
like that and so what ended up happening
here is emma frost actually assembled
the marauders and then immediately
sailed to the location of where bishop
was at and this is when you get to see
one of these amazing moments with iceman
right it's not super lengthy but as
these guys are making their way through
here suddenly everything starts getting
cold and then these guys start to freeze
up right and one of the guys like like
the marauders are here you know and then
they realize it's iceman right and the
crazy thing is one of these guys starts
stripping off his clothes and he's like
god i'm absolutely burning out by just
just losing his mind suddenly like the
door bus open and you get just this
amazing full page splash of ice man and
he's just like murderers right this guy
is pissed and that's one of the things
remember the rule of krakowa kill no man
and so bobby drake doesn't kill them but
he certainly tortures them right like he
freezes them to the point that their
fingers start breaking off he rips off
one of their arms he basically gives
these guys frostbite not enough to kill
him but enough to make them suffer and
that's the crazy thing here is you never
really see bobby drake do this and it's
awesome to see it happen and so he tells
these guys frostbite never quite fully
heals you've lost arms you've lost legs
you've lost digits keep this as a memory
keep this as a reminder of the things
that you're experiencing here keep this
as a reminder of what happens when you
lay hands against the mutant population
and so what you get following this is
you switch over to the marauders once
they return back to krakow and then you
get this really weird kind of situation
with pyro right the guy who can
manipulate fire where like once he
arrives you have like jean grey sitting
on his car she's like hey i was hoping
you can give me a ride now only to find
out that it's all just kind of a
scenario that emma frost is putting on
and she's not doing it arbitrarily or
whimsically she's doing this because of
the fact that something is in the mind
of pyro the pyro has basically been
spying on the entirety of the marauders
and comings and goings from kokoa but
it's not really him that's doing it in
fact it's actually one of the virendi in
a little tiny itty bitty microscopic
submarine sitting in his body and so
once everything kicks off right once
they realize or at least once this guy
realizes that essentially the jig is up
he's been caught he immediately expands
right he enlarges destroys pyro and then
annihilates emma frost in the process
and then basically bails out to
madrapore right now here's the beauty of
all this it's a ruse none of it actually
happened instead as soon as all this
went down as soon as emma frost realized
that pyro was basically not really
possessed that's not really the right
phrase to use but somebody was
essentially piloting pyro if you can
call it that she basically called
together the separate cocoons magneto
and then bishop and it's all just
basically a trick using a combination of
emma frost's powers which are basically
kind of being bolstered and enhanced by
the stepford kakoos they created that
entire illusion around what is basically
yellow jacket not hank pym yellow
jacket's just the name this guy is using
but ultimately magneto while this
yellowjacket guy is having this whole
illusion believing that he's sailing
back to madrapore and he's going to be
back with a verity and everything is
going to be cool that magneto pulls a
submarine out and then basically just
sends it flying right now of course the
entire incident and all this had been
wiped from the mind of yellowjackets so
we couldn't actually report to the
verity what happened but it's one of
those crazy things because this is one
of those instances when somebody managed
to completely infiltrate the mutant
population and that's one of the things
that i hope you guys are noticing here
is that this kind of a situation has
happened on a few different occasions
that one of the first things marvel
established when it came to the mutant
nation of kakawa they're not
invulnerable they're not immune to
infiltration or being taken over by some
force out there that at the end of the
day they cannot guard every door
successfully and somebody will make
their way in but the way that emma frost
gets her point across is fantastic here
so what she does is she basically bonds
or at least you know takes the hand of
pyro and then she essentially says okay
let's begin the opening remarks and so
what you have is like the virindi right
cade kilgore and all these young kids
these members of this kind of new
hellfire club who were talking about
their home in madrid celebrating their
success and then emma frost chimes in
telepathy right says yes yes lift a
glass of the good stuff to your big
secret spy mission yellow jacket is on
his way back to you here in madrid he
won't remember a thing but do warn him
not to land in krakowa again and then
she says frankly i'm embarrassed for you
your children playing a game mirroring
our old club i do hope you guys grow up
right and she says this is the only
warning you will receive to stay out of
mutant shipping lanes i pride myself on
being the cooler head because there are
mutants whose blood runs much hotter
than mine and using her power of
telepathy she basically forces the
virendi to experience what it's like to
be burned alive at the hands of pyro now
this is a huge deal because at the end
of the day the verindi really were just
kids playing a grownups game right when
it comes to the hellfire club they'd
been doing this for a long long long
time right they were very influential
very very powerful these kids have no
idea what they're doing and so it was
kind of funny to see emma frost
appearing to this kind of remade version
of the hellfire club of these younger
kids and just being like like i mean
it's cute what you're doing here but
come on guys you're painfully out of
your league right it's a cool little
thing to see and so what you end up
doing is switching back to kokoa and the
efforts to basically resurrect kitty
pride and it cannot be done for one
reason or another kitty pride never
emerges from her cocoon seemingly there
doesn't seem to be a way to get her out
of there and so what you do is you
switch over to the quiet council and you
actually find out emma frost isn't there
instead she sent sophie of the step for
cocoons who's probably one of the more
powerful members of the group even if
you really can have a hierarchy of power
among the stepford crews technically
sophie is i mean at the end of the day
they are all clones of emma frost but
the important thing here is that emma
frost isn't here and sophie says the
reason why is because when bishop hacked
the madraport government he found that
there was intelligence basically coming
from the virindi that basically showed a
kind of cooperation between the virindi
supported averindi-backed governments in
madrid russia and brazil and there's a
freighter that is operated by the
russians that's responsible for
producing weapons using forge's old
designs that serve the purpose of
generating weapons that can destroy the
mutant population and so essentially
emma frost and the marauders have just
kind of sailed out there to destroy the
whole thing and so that's when you
actually get this really interesting
moment when magneto lifts his helmet
slightly enough that his mind you can
kind of get a thought out but not enough
that anybody can really do anything and
then basically tells sophie or at least
allows her to overhear his his words
telepathically and says tell the white
queen to leave none to tell the tale
basically kill everybody right that's
what magneto really seems to be saying
here now it's one of those things when
you kind of have to read between the
lines because the rules say kill no man
magneto doesn't say kill everybody he
just says leave no one to tell the tale
which you can interpret a couple
different ways but what you end up
getting is kind of switching over to
this freighter basically they're met by
iceman who literally creates a giant
iceberg and lifts the freighter into the
air so it can't actually go anywhere and
then like emma frost shows up with the
mercury now the mercury we've seen
before we saw it marauders number five
but initially it looked like a submarine
turns out it's a ufo and we don't know
how in the world they managed to get
their hands on it i mean in all honesty
it's not that strange when you consider
like the grand scheme of marvel comics i
mean for god's sake like we literally
this is the line of comics that
publishes stories about a giant guy in a
purple suit that eats planets is it
really that strange to believe the x-men
could get their hands on a ufo
but nonetheless you know it's one of
these things where it just kind of goes
part and parcel to the somewhat fun and
silly nature of the story but also
keeping that kind of seriousness going
at the same time and so ultimately you
end up having like emma frost and pyro
making their way through there when
they're suddenly met by the arrival of a
bunch of russian soldiers now at that
point emma frost kind of unbuttons their
shirt she doesn't really show them the
goods but she gives them enough that
their imagination can kind of run wild
and then using that has them all shoot
each other up right so let's i guess
that works right you know use it as a
distraction and then following that you
actually have one of these guys who
intends to detonate the entire ship
because he was basically instructed that
this ship is not to be captured under
any circumstances that if mutants
infiltrated or any other kind of enemy
force infiltrates it that he blows the
whole thing to pieces and then callisto
appears and what's probably one of the
most callistoey lines ever where she's
like i get that you're prepared to die
but are you prepared to die slowly one
piece at a time
i absolutely love that phrase i love
that that's absolutely amazing of course
emma frost is able to kind of overcome
all this and then ultimately they end up
wiping the minds of all these guys so
it's not really an execute everybody on
board mission instead what you end up
getting is emma frost essentially
modifying their memory so they'll have
no real recollection of this the other
thing she does is she modifies their
minds in such a way to where they will
never show bigotry towards anybody it
doesn't matter where they stand in the
way that they live their lives that if
they express bigotry towards a person
that's different than them they'll
actually experience physical sickness
right which is probably something we
could have a little more of in this
world and then of course using the ufo
they destroy the freighter and they
leave right it's interesting
it's a little wonky and a little wild
but what you actually end up getting
here is this really really cool
revelation right so following the
funeral this put on for kitty pry due to
the fact that they basically seem to
give up on the idea of resurrecting her
because there doesn't really seem to be
a way to bring her back that what ends
up happening is that while emma frost is
grieving over the loss of kitty pride
then suddenly lockheed returned now
remember lockheed was with kitty pride
at the time that she that she had her
powers nullified using cocoon seeds by
sebastian shaw and then thrown into the
ocean to drown in his hubris shaw didn't
check to see if lockheed was alive and
the fact that he is and the fact that
emma frost can read the mind of lockheed
basically reveals that sebastian shaw
was the one who took out kitty pride
right sebastian shaw was the one that
did her in and this is when emma frost
starts to lose it and her initial
inclination is to kill sebastian shaw
but before that she's like no no no
we're gonna make him suffer first right
we're gonna make him suffer first we're
gonna worry about kitty pride then we'll
worry about him and so once lockheed is
taken to the healing gardens and
basically xavier explains to uh to emma
frost that again kind of a reminder
there doesn't really seem to be a way to
bring back uh bring back kitty pride
that they're attempting it one last time
but it just never really seems to work
that she never breaks out of her husk
that's when it dawns on emma frost no
kitty pry never breaks out of anything
wouldn't you ever see kitty pride kick
down a door or smash through a wall
you've never seen her do that mutants
here normally do that because they don't
have the powers that kitty pride has
kitty pride has the power to phase
through objects but up to this point she
wasn't aware that she had that power so
quite literally all the times that they
were trying to resurrect her she didn't
know she could phase through her husk
and ultimately all these versions of her
that were resurrected just basically
ended up drowning and so that's when
emma frost uses her powers to remind
kittypride that she can faze and
actually grabs kittypride's hand and
pulls her through and that's what allows
kittypride to get out following that
xavier uses her powers returns kitty
pride's memories back to her to a degree
and then in turn she's basically reborn
here and one of the first things the
kittypride asks with everything going on
one of the first things she asks here is
where's sebastian shaw with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end keep your eye out for the
video for the i guess later on today for
the second part of this when they
actually catch up with sebastian shaw
and they help him understand his place
in the bigger picture in probably the
best way ever and i will catch you all
later
peace